yeah so um why don't you start Eddie
um toxic relationship yeah yeah I've
been the one
what's the most toxic thing that I did
nothing it was all her it was mostly her
still I'll be rolly yeah it was mostly
hairstyle nothing it doesn't take too
detangle I'm serious I think probably
the most toxic thing I did was I checked
the phone once
that's probably the most toxic thing
that I did so um I also have a
whiteboard for this part of the okay
where I'm gonna write things on the
Whiteboard and we get to decide as a
group toxic or not toxic
and then and then the most toxic thing
she told me because she told me that
there was like a scale of toxicity of
crazy [__] that she did like cycle [__]
that she did and she was the least
psycho thing she did was that she used
to message me to ask if I was at home
and then she'll drive past a window to
check if I was actually in WoW
she used to go up to girls that I knew
and be like just know that
um I know you you're in the same class
as Eddie this is like Unity I know
you're in the same class as Eddie just
just went to let you know that I know
that she's getting Sia badge what
possible
she's wasted
yeah
mad oh what am I going to put on the
board wait what did you do that was
toxic I I should say I checked the phone
okay fine
you said in a relationship in a
relationship
listen speak your mind man you want this
mic is checking your phone in a
relationship toxic
I wanna do hands so if yes it's toxic
raise your hands
in a phone
okay you're looking for trouble Man
exactly when you when you seek you shall
find in it but the only reason I did it
it's because she used to love doing it
yeah so then she used to love doing it
so one time I said let me check your
phone actually got bad defensive oh so I
was like hmm something's fishy here yes
and then when I pre-dip my heart sank
bro for real my immune system shut down
I got covered before even covet happened
I'm sorry
what'd you find the maddest Texas
just the whole do you know what most of
all just but you just find bad lives you
just find bad lies saying you're in
certain places when you're not and
you're with certain people and you're
not it was long still
so she said the least toxic thing that
were the things she could tell me the
most sorry the least cycle of things she
did that she could tell me about no is
that she would text me to check whether
I was in and then she would drive past
my window to check if my light was on if
I was actually there
[Laughter]
back in the day to do checks
in Tottenham in Cornell College using
like a guy's
to go and check for my friend to see if
he was really there doing his doing was
he
but I helped my friend out we were like
16. I just want to say I don't have the
capacity cheats okay what about you have
you ever been in a toxic relationship
and if so what was the most toxic thing
you both did okay so yeah of course like
because I think everyone said yes
um most toxic thing I probably did in
that relationship
was I mean at that time I was it was
many years ago and I was using a lot of
coke and and different drugs and things
like that and I was basically convincing
her to sell for me which was hey hey
ride or die I'm not I'm not gonna lie I
wasn't
hey hey we could phrase it the right way
helping with a business yeah that's
literally what I was thinking she's
supporting the humanity made it sound
more coercive than it was like an
apprentice when I was out of town when I
was out of town she would do it for me
she was more than willing but I was
still using her for that that's not
toxic that's not toxic I don't think
that's toxic we're gonna raise hands
anyways
it's not about me
that's called Joint Enterprise
all right having your girls sell drugs
for you raise your hand toxic she agreed
she wanted to make money did she want to
make money and did it all go to her your
girl's a hustler bro you
know there was no question
okay okay
I don't know we're trying this again
we're trying to look at that in two days
guys we're trying this again raise your
hand if that's toxic
I'm gonna put alive all right I'm a
hustler I'm a hustler homie
I'm gonna say no she's an entrepreneur
[Music]
but the things she did that was toxic
was she she didn't take responsibility
for her emotions but what she would do
is when she would get upset she would do
everything she could to try and make me
lose my temper so she would like shout
and scream at my face and if I went I'm
not having an argument and try and
walked away she would like follow me out
into the street and like grab hold of me
screaming and shouting the road down
trying to make out like you know you
[__] up bro you meant to choke her and
say bend over I know Karma down street
yeah troll can say babe shut up and then
give her a little bit of wood I see she
don't say baby I love you
baby I'm sorry I said that
listen for the money no
no no
I'm not taking your advice all right all
right
let me let me know how that goes
okay so making him lose his temper yeah
I'm just gonna put talk yeah yeah yeah
okay so so what about you
no bro
come on say with chess
come on
to be fair he lied about his name
I need to think about I ain't thinking
about Kobe test
I think my immune system is playing up
foreign
I had the reason to be scared this is
why I'm scared this dude was a whole
different someone with a fake passport
okay okay and a baby and a baby in Ghana
bro
what you still did was worse yeah we
said you cheated is worse
I don't give a [__]
yeah
excuse just because you're young like I
mean you knew what you do like honestly
when you're over like 17 you're doing
16. no it's okay over that too he's a
big woman I mean
I mean my dick at first
and you lied because he owned up to his
life
I end up eventually
was that by choice
I'm gonna just put talks
because think about it wasn't just
another guy it was a sugar daddy yeah
man was funding the thing yeah oh so
it's not only getting the Tonton he's
paying for the tunes
honestly I feel like
we're talking to women
they'll be like oh you're you're dude at
a family across town mine had three
I don't need
to cry and beat you're guilty guilty
guilty you know what here hold on I'm
gonna put a red flag
that's something to say
yeah yeah I'm sorry I'm gonna I'm gonna
put I can't even think of anything now
anyone else speaking to slide in the DMS
cancel the mission or bought mission
a long time ago yeah
I'm backing you here people
an excuse me I had checked out you could
how old was the sugar I just I can't it
was it that information
12 years older than me
okay okay 15.
okay okay hold up hold on one second
how old was you
yeah
okay you got more red flags than a golf
course
[Laughter]
I'm gonna draw YouTube I was in pain
I was in pain I'm gonna draw the ladies
of the show oh
my God why not the men I don't actually
just kept quiet like now I'm like no no
I respect honesty but I'm terrified
of 24. you did it properly oh yeah I
feel bad there's no costs go all in I
went to I went to therapy for three
years I have to support yeah
oh you went to therapy okay hold on hold
on
oh you're still in therapy hold on
several batches okay
you have to own up to your [__] like you
can't pretend to be okay I'm not want to
pretend to be okay oh okay I want
Perfection I'm trying to be my best
well can I say what he did to me go
ahead go ahead what'd he do what do you
do
monitoring spirits he those one time
like basically he used to eavesdrop on
my conversations he this is before I
cheated on him right so paranoid
about me yes because some guys is when
you get with them The Knife Guy the one
that doesn't get the girls they can't
believe they've got you so they become
your surveillance and this is where he
wasn't my type I said you know what I
want the nice guy but the nice guy
couldn't believe he won oh but see
that's what they say they're dating bad
boys I had daddy issues so he was the
guy he was the guy that was quiet he was
respectful he was kind he was calm but
he couldn't believe in himself that he
actually got me but then he started
being extra with monitoring my phone
checking my phone to the point where I
went out one time to use the pay phone
to have a private conversation with my
girlfriend and I turned around and this
dude is standing by the glass family I
was like nah is that breathing on the
window
but this is where they say you can't
this is why they say you can't date a
girl after she's dated bad guys because
she'll cheat on the nice guy with the
bad boys
yeah I mean it doesn't it doesn't matter
I agree it doesn't matter what he was
doing like he lied about his whole life
I mean as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible